all right ba Nick nobody in major league
history has hit two home runs on
back-to-back postseason games but you
just did and you guys are headed to the
NLCS where's the question inight there's
no question well than thank you for
telling me I thought you'd be happy with
that uh I am man but we got eight more
wins here's a question you guys were 14
games behind them in the standings in
the regular season how did you did you
dispatch the best team in the regular
season so
quickly
there's no easy answer to that the only
thing that I can say is that I'm
learning that the season and the
postseason are completely different you
won your first postseason game nine
years into your career last year how
gratifying are these moments Now
Incredible I'll never forget him you've
got home field now for the NLCS as well
with Arizona coming in you've got
wheeler lined up to start game one with
Nola right behind him how good do you
feel about where you're headed
we feel good there's no question about
it but you know we're definitely going
to respect the competition and do what
we can do how great is at having these
kinds of moments in the postseason in
front of this crowd they don't they
don't sit for most of the night they're
they're never
quiet it's been an incredible scene what
is it like to be in the middle of it
like I said man this is these are
moments I'm never going to forget
congratulations thank you chice
congratulations you just took out the
best team in baseball in the regular
season why was it so dominant from your
perspective that's a really good team
over there and they played such a great
year this year and I have so much
respect for them and the way they go
about it um what type of team they are
one through nine their pitching staff as
well um and we just did so good tonight
I mean coming in here playing in front
of this fan base there's nothing like it
whole field advantage is real and you
know Ranger threw really well our
Bullpen came in shut the door huge two
two swings by castios and uh Trey Turner
and that's why they're here that's why
you spend the money baby 11 home runs
over the series six over the last couple
of games how good do you feel about
where this offense is right now yeah
we're excited man we uh I think we're
all clicking on the same cylinder we got
a couple guys that could do it a little
bit more and you know I think we get
that going you know we're tough to beat
so um we just lined up our pitching as
well our onew Ace uh going first game
and second game Arizona's really good as
well they're hot they're young um they
got some pretty good pitching as well
and we're excited for the series yeah
what is it mean to have home field here
for the NLCS there's nothing like it
it's the best fan base in America um in
the world I mean it's unbelievable
coming in here it's hard to play in here
and we know that um so we're going to go
in and have some fun Monday night you
came back out to first base but I got to
ask how's the elbow I'm good just hit my
Funny Bone so feels better now I imagine
yeah I'm fine congratulations thank you
appreciate it